quand même quelle drôle de titre
libérez votre tchibo sionnel d'abord sa
tendance chic où ça se prononce situe en
fait parmi vous vraisemblement la
plupart du temps vous connaissez tous ça
qui a entendu parler du tchi kong
je pense que ça représente la plupart
d'entre vous je vois mal mais je pense
que ça représente la plupart d'entre eux
est en fait donc non seulement vous le
connaissez sur le plan intellectuel mais
vous le connaissez sur le plan du
ressorti parce qu'à chaque fois que vous
faites quelque chose que vous aimez bien
dans un secteur dans lequel vous êtes
compétent et de quelques elle vous avez
un certain niveau à chaque fois quand
vous ressentez quelque chose
d'extraordinaire
quand vous faites quelque chose que vous
n'avez pas l'habitude de faire et que ça
marche
à ce moment là vous ressentez nous
ressentons tous un bien-être vraiment
une énergie quelque chose de très
agréable et c'est ça que j'appelle le
tchi maintenant deux petites précisions
avant de que d'aller plus loin
d'abord chez émotionnel pourquoi
émotionnel tout simplement pour faire
une distinction entre le tchi qu'on peut
avoir dans les arts martiaux ou d'un des
activités physiques et le cicc on peut
avoir dans les relations entre les gens
et c'est ça dont je vais vous parler ce
soir
autre précision mais pourquoi libérer le
chi dont sept dans cette journée qui
dans le titre c'est casser les murs en
fait ceux çi il est là il est présent en
chacun d'entre nous
la difficulté c'est que nous n'arrivons
pas à le mettre en oeuvre
suffisamment souvent ou suffisamment à
chaque fois que nous voulons nous le
voulons et pourquoi nous n'arrivons pas
à le mettre en oeuvre
parce que nous avons toutes sortes de
murs en nous et autour de nous qui nous
empêche d'y avoir accès donc l'objectif
pour moi aujourd'hui c'est de vous
transmettre un certain nombre de
principes et d'astuces qui doit vous
permettre si mon objectif est atteint 2
à ce que
puissiez avoir accès à sotchi ce soir
demain matin et d'un jours qui viennent
cela fait maintenant plus de 20 ans que
je coach des managers et des dirigeants
dans des entreprises petites ou beaucoup
plus importante et à chaque fois je suis
frappé par le fait que tous les gens
avec lesquels je travaille ont un
potentiel très nettement supérieur à
celui à celui très nettement supérieur à
celui qu'ils utilisent et de façon plus
générale puisque c'est vraiment le sujet
sur lequel je travaille partout et tout
le temps
ce que je peux ce dont je suis convaincu
aujourd'hui c'est que nous avons tous un
potentiel très supérieur à celui que
nous utilisons donc dans cette salle
vous tous vous avez un potentiel très
nettement supérieur à celui que vous
utilisez et mon objectif c'est de donner
donc encore une fois des astuces des
trucs pourquoi utiliser plus et mieux ce
potentiel alors deux exemples de
personnes qui ont réussi ce qu'ils ont
réussi à utiliser plus et mieux se
passer le premier il s'appelle marc
marque
à l'époque je l'aï rencontré il était
contrôleur de gestion dans une
entreprise assurance est ce quelqu'un
qui avait 35 ans trois enfants de bonnes
études compétences des cinq ans qui
était dans l'entreprise et ça se passait
plutôt pas mal
le problème c'est que depuis quelques
mois il avait touché
il avait récupéré un nouveau responsable
hiérarchique et ce responsable
hiérarchique avait acquis au fortement
plutôt autoritaire cassant alors que lui
marque était quelqu'un qui est est
toujours quelqu'un plutôt introverti et
donc dès les premiers temps dès les
premiers temps ça se passait pas très
bien entre les deux vraiment il ya
quelque chose ça ça collait pas quoi et
au bout de quelques temps qu'au bout de
quelques semaines
mark a fait une ou deux erreurs qui
était vraiment pas des erreurs très
importante
le seul problème c'est que ça
profondément agacé son manager et son
responsable hiérarchique et à partir de
ce moment là il a commencé à lui mettre
la pression
et bien entendu comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer plus ils mettaient la
pression sur mark plus marc percée des
perdait ses moyens plus ces résultats se
dégradaient
et bien entendu c'est un vrai cercle
vicieux parce que plus les résultats se
dégrader plus le manager attaquer et au
moment où j'ai commencé à travailler
avec lui parce que heureusement sow
l'environnement rh lui avait permis
d'avoir un coach et donc on a pu
travailler avec lui au moment où j'ai
commencé avec lui il était vraiment pas
bien du tout et donc quand j'ai
travaillé avec lui disent entretien à
peu près et ce qui était très agréable
c'était que des troisièmes quatrièmes
entretiens
ça a commencé à changer et donc oui le
problème de marque c'était qu'il était
de plus en plus enfermer évoqué ici
c'était comme s'il y avait des murs qui
se construisait et qui l'empêché de
s'exprimer de d'atteindre d'utiliser son
potentiel et en quelques semaines
quelques entretiens il a commencé à puer
pouvoir se reconstruire et reconstruire
et re recontacter cette énergie ce
potentiel et au bout de quelques mois ça
allait beaucoup mieux et il a pu changer
de job il a pu retrouver un poste qui
lui allait beaucoup mieux
et de fil en aiguille il est remonté et
aujourd'hui il a fait une très très
belle carrière je le vois régulièrement
encore et donc nous entendons très bien
et ça se passe très bien pour lui autre
cas de figure très différents etienne
etienne lui est très sain manager qui a
une énergie colossale et des résultats à
la hauteur
il est vraiment c'est quelqu'un qui a
des résultats opérationnels mais
vraiment absolument incroyable il a été
recruté il ya deux ans et c'est dans une
industrie dans le domaine de l'industrie
il a une quarantaine d'années deux
enfants ça se passe très bien et sait et
il était recruté pour accompagner le
changement et faciliter et accélérer le
changement
dans cette entreprise ça se passe très
bien depuis deux ans il a pu lui a fait
gagner à son entreprise plusieurs
centaines de milliards d'euros et donc
grosso modo tout va bien quoi donc bien
entendu de temps en temps ça se passe
pas très bien avec certaines personnes
m'enfin bon avec les certaine demi
deux roues qui a fait à gagner à son
service quand même pas de problème et
donc entretien avec sa drh pour
envisager les postes après donc dans
deux ans trois ans qu'est ce que je vais
faire et à ce moment là
douche froide parce que ça déraille fait
dit ok c'est vrai très riche a de très
bons résultats personnels et sa personne
peut être enlevé le seul problème c'est
que tu as des comportements par moments
autoritaire et kasso et que ça vraiment
cette pénible pour les gens qui
travaillent toit et j'ai fait le tour
des principaux responsables de division
dans lequel en principe devrait pouvoir
y travailler et personne ne veut de toi
autrement dit si tu ne changes pas des
comportements dans les mois qui viennent
dans deux autres pas de job on peut pas
de garder donc vous imaginez que la
situation était très inconfortable donc
là aussi on lui a donné les moyens et
j'ai pu travailler avec lui
et hélas c'était extraordinaire parce
que pratiquement au cours du premier
entretien
tout à coup il ya eu un flash il a
compris ce qui se passait chez lui et
l'a compris ce qui se passait chez les
autres et l'a compris grosso modo qu'est
ce qu'on pouvait faire pour changer les
choses
tout à coup il avait le mode d'emploi
qu'il cherchait depuis des années sans
vraiment de sens a partout et et comme
c'est quelqu'un qui est extrêmement
orientée sur les résultats comme comme
vous pouvez l'imaginer
donc il sait remonter les manches et
puis ici amis et en quelques semaines il
avait changé vraiment tous les
comportements les plus importants et les
plus embêtant par rapport à ses
collaborateurs et par rapport à ses
interlocuteurs il avait réussi elle
ajouté bon c'était pas encore parfait
mais déjà ça allait beaucoup mieux et la
drh a pu revoir comment ça se passait et
commence à changer
et donc ça s'est amélioré en quelques
mois ça a très bien marché je me faisais
travailler avec lui
huit des entretiens et au bout d'eux
vraiment avant avant un an
il a obtenu un poste qui n'était pas du
tout dans ses avoirs et qui était très
nettement au dessus de ski du poste
qu'il avait parce que effectivement tout
le monde durant 16 sept
ses capacités opérationnelles
extraordinaire il s'est vraiment
quelqu'un qui a très très bon manager
est là dans son nouveau poste ça se
passe très très bien
la seul problème c'était c'est c'est
comportement est en fait vous voyez ces
initiales là aussi c'est une histoire de
çi c'est une sorte de mur les murs là
c'est pas les murs qui l'art lui c'est
les murs qui se construisent à
l'extérieur de lui pour se protéger de
son impact est donc l'idée c'est
effectivement comment on peut arriver à
apprivoiser le chico est trop fort
apprivoiser cette énergie interne quand
elle est trop forte qu'elle sorte ma est
au contraire la libérer quand elle est
bloquée donc la très grossièrement donc
je vais vous présenter appelé les
schémas globaux qui peut utiliser puis
après on va rentrer dans des choses plus
concrètes que vous pourriez faire parce
que mon objectif c'est effectivement que
ce soir ou demain vous commencez à faire
un certain nombre de choses de façon
différente donc les trois savoir-faire
sur lequel il faut travailler et sur les
trois que ça va faire sur lesquels ils
ont travaillé c'est comprendre calme et
communiquer ce qu'elle appelle les 3c
comprendre il s'agit de comprendre
qu'est ce qui se passe en moi
et qu'est ce qui se passe chez les
autres quand le stress monte et comparé
commence à partir dans des réactions qui
sont plutôt des réactions automatiques
le calme et il s'agit de me calmer mois
et de calmer les autres parce que tant
que nous sommes sous tension contactez
nous sommes sous stress notre cerveau
une partie de nos ne fonctionne plus et
docks à ce moment là donc s'il ya ces
réactions automatiques dont il faut
absolument arriver à calmer le jeu et
communiqué c'est absolument fondamental
d'arriver à faire passer ses idées avec
fermeté et sans agressivité
parce que si vous avez compris ce qui se
passe si vous avez calmer le jeu mais
que rien ne change
bien entendu la situation va recommencer
à se dégrader très rapidement donc il
faut absolument arriver à faire passer
vos messages et à faire changer les
choses
donc là on est quand même sur des
catégories qui sont assez importantes
donc par rapport à vous ce que vous
pouvez faire c'est pas encore assez
précis donc 4 savoir-faire quatre
petites éléments très concrets qui sont
dans ces différents registres que vous
allez pouvoir commencer à utiliser le
premier c'est dans le domaine de
comprendre donc comprendre effectivement
que
sous stress une partie de nos neurones
ne fonctionne pas et à ce moment là on
passe en mode automatique avec trois
types de registre soit agressivité soit
de l'agitation soit de blocage de la
saisine et de la tétanisation et ce sont
ces réactions émotionnelles instinctive
chez nous ou chez les autres qui
construisent des murs ont construit les
murs pour se protéger que ça soit nous
que les conclusions les autres qui
construisent mais façon il ya toujours
ces éléments d'attaqué de défense et ont
construit des murs entre les deux pour
les empêcher
donc là par rapport à ça ce qui est
intéressant c'est de comprendre que
derrière chacune de ces comportements
il ya une distinction il faut faire une
distinction entre la personne et ses
comportements
ces comportements sont des comportements
automatique
ce n'est pas la personne qui veut être
agressive
ce sont ses réflexes qui font que dans
certaines situations elle devient
agressive la même chose ce sont c'est
pas la personne qui veut s'agiter qui
peut parler beaucoup ce sont ses
réflexes automatiques qui font que la
personne va commencer à se mettre à
s'agiter
autre élément très important c'est que
derrière chacune de ces réactions
automatiques instinctive
il ya un besoin qui n'est pas satisfait
autrement dit il ya une logique
il ya une logique dans le domaine des
réactions émotionnelles
à partir du moment où vous comprenez que
quelqu'un qui s'agitent c'est qu'il ya
un besoin qui n'est pas satisfait et qui
a besoin souvent de liberté de sécurité
à partir du moment où vous comprenez que
d'ailleurs eu un comportement agressif
vous avez un besoin de reconnaissance ou
un besoin de résultats qui n'est pas
satisfait vous allez pouvoir agir ce
besoin faire en sorte que vous
accueillez la réaction négative
agressive par exemple
et d'évoquer bon c'est pas lui qui
agresse yves c'est juste son crocodile
sa réaction instinctive qui est
agressive et donc d'ailleurs vous gérer
cette réaction et vous parler à la
personne
donc ça c'est pour le côté calmer et
après des choses encore plus donc non ça
ne pardonne pas partie comprendre pour
la partie calme et là je vous recommande
d'aller voir sur internet quelque chose
qui s'appelle la cohérence cardiaque
ça vous allez pouvoir trouver toutes
sortes d'éléments qui vont vous
permettre de faire baisser votre système
nerveux quand vous êtes trop sous
tension et ce qui est très intéressant
de l'alcool cardiaque c'est qu'en plus
vous pouvez charger sur votre téléphone
une petite application qui va vous
permettre de respirer de calmer votre
système nerveux et de vous apaiser et
donc faire en sorte que quand vous êtes
trop énervés ou trop bas j'étais vous
arriviez à ramener système en pas ce
qu'il faut juste comprendre aussi c'est
que il ya quelque chose pour les impôts
élargit un peu
aujourd'hui nous avons agi et venant
voir tous les êtres humains aux deux
systèmes nerveux à système nerveux
sympathique et un système nerveux
parasympathique le système certes
nerveux sympathique vous permet de c'est
celui qui veut vous met en position de
battre ou de courir à c'est celui qui va
générer de la tan aline et vous avez un
autre système nerveux qui le système
nerveux parasympathique qui lui a pour
mission de une fois que le temps j'ai
passé de ramener tout ça de ramener le
calme
et aujourd'hui nous avons toutes sortes
de techniques toutes sortes de pratiques
qui font que nous pouvons déclencher la
production le fonctionnement notre
système nerveux parasympathique à la
demande si vous allez voir un
sophrologue une sophrologue et que vous
lui demander de travailler sur un
ancrage vous pouvez arriver à faire en
sorte que dans une situation stressante
vous puissiez avoir comme un bouton vous
appuyer sur vos doigts et vous
déclenchez le fonctionnement de votre
système nerveux parasympathique et ça
produit en vous tout une chimie interne
à base de dopamine cirotteau nine
endorphines etc et donc vous pouvez vous
pouvez pas le faire tout seul près
seulement moi ça autant la cohérence
cardiaque vous pouvez le faire autant le
reste il faut aller voir un sophrologue
ou un hypnothérapeute experts mais ça
existe sachez le parce que c'est
vraiment très agréable et tous les gens
qui se font aujourd'hui la compétition
du sport de haut niveau travail ce genre
de registre troisième registre le
domaine de la communication
donc dans ce domaine accueille nication
ça c'est là vous allez pouvoir dès ce
soir dès demain matin
très très sympa et qui se vouent pauvres
qui vont être très utile première chose
vous en avez certainement entendu parler
c'est écouter et reformulé même et
surtout si ça ne vous plaît pas même et
surtout si on vous attaque
écoutez et reformulé ok donc ce que tu
en train de me dire c'est ça ça et ça
c'est parce que c'est parce que moi je
n'ai pas bien expliqué le ce que je t'ai
demandé que tu n'as pas réussi à le
faire
ou tu considères que ces voix qui le
suit à la cause de cet élément et ne
vous contentez pas sacef c'est quand
même un bouclier ne vous contentez pas
de ce bouclier bien entendu défendez
vous quand même
et pour vous défendre supprimez tous vos
mets et remplacez les par b et si même
si vous n'êtes pas du tout d'accord dit
ok j'entends que toi tu penses que la
situation et noir de chez noir et moi je
pense que vraiment il ya toutes sortes
d'éléments positifs dans cette situation
donc ça ce sont deux éléments très très
simple très concrets que vous pouvez
mettre en place dès ce soit et vous
allez voir ça change énormément de
choses dans vos relations avec votre
environnement et vos proches et surtout
maintenant bien entendu il ya un autre
élément quand même parce que je coach
beaucoup de gens j'accompagne beaucoup
de gens et mais tout le monde ne met pas
tout le monde aille pas a changé oui et
ses principes ils ont très très simple
la difficulté le problème c'est souvent
à rivel mettre en oeuvre et là en fait
changé ce sont des changements
d'habitudes comportementale et vous
savez tous ce faire vous savez tous
changer de comportement parce que vous
l'avez déjà fait plusieurs fois
surtout dans les domaines dans lequel
vous avez fait beaucoup de progrès dans
lequel vous êtes bon pour arriver à
changer un comportement il faut trois
choses très simples la première chose
c'est il faut avoir envie
si vous n'avez pas envie d'arrêter de
fumer ça sert à rien si vous n'avez pas
envie de perdre du poids ça ne sert à
rien si vous n'avez pas envie de faire
de la musculation est vraiment me sentir
bien dans votre peau ça ne sert à rien
donc il faut d'abord avoir énormément
envie
le deuxième point c'est demander à
quelqu'un qui sait ça sert à rien de
réinventer
l'eau tiède le fil à couper le beurre
etc demandez à ceux qui savent que ce
soit des amis des experts des
enseignants des profs des coachs et
s'est demandé à ceux qui savent
troisième élément pratiquer pratiquer
pratiquer pour changer un comportement
pour utiliser le et à la place du mais
il n'ya qu'une seule chose à faire
essayez est pratiquée pour ça y est une
illustration que j'adore c'est
l'illustration du surf
même si et je pense que pour vous elle
vous parle aussi même si vous n'avez
jamais pratiqué de surf on n'apprend pas
à faire du surf dans un bouquin dans un
cours ou sur la plage le seul moyen
d'apprendre à tenir debout sur une
planche à voile c'est vous sur un surf
c'est de monter dessus
même si l'eau est froide de tomber de
recommencer de recommencer jusqu'à ce
que ça marche donc pratiquer pratiquer
pratiquer maintenant dernier point il ya
un élément qui est vraiment important
pour arriver à faire tout ça c'est en
avoir envie et voilà ce que vous pouvez
gagner si ça marche voilà en fait vous
savez tous et où vous l'avez tous
expérimentés quand on arrive à faire
quelque chose d'un peu difficile c'est
génial on a un plaisir extraordinaire à
le faire et donc ce que vous pouvez
gagner à faire ces petits changements
comportementaux
bienvenue au début ça sera peut-être un
peu difficile mais après
quel plaisir quel bonheur maintenant je
voudrais juste avant de terminer
rajouter quelques mots donc ces
changements de comportements qui vont
vous permettre d'avoir accès à votre chi
d'avoir vraiment des relations
d'enrichir vos relations avec votre
environnement et avec vous même
faites-le d'abord pour vous parce que
c'est vraiment vous allez ressentir
beaucoup de plaisir et c'est ça qui va
vous mettre dans un cercle vertueux et
ne le fait pas uniquement pauvres
faites-le également pour les autres
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans un monde
dans lequel les tensions sont de plus en
plus nombreuses et risque d'être de plus
en plus nombreuses ces tensions génèrent
des réactions émotionnelles d' agressive
et de peurs et de blocage ces réactions
émotionnelles génère elle-même des murs
psychique la construction de nouveaux
murs psychique et même physique
le seul moyen que nous ayons aujourd'hui
d'arriver à limiter les dégâts de ces
tensions c'est que nous soyons de plus
en plus nombreux à pratiquer ce genre de
choses à savoir apaiser les tensions
réduire les tensions et ne nous même
être beaucoup plus calme et vraiment je
vous encourage à le faire donc pour vous
mais à le faire également pour vos
proches et à le faire pour votre
environnement et l faire pour nous tous
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase de ghandi
soyons le changement que nous voulons
voir advenir aujourd'hui dans le monde
merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]